right it's the retrospective show yeah
talking about a little bit of a
lesser-known
Ridley Scott movie that I had actually
completely forgotten about until a week
or two ago yeah I saw it as a kid just
like on on cable and it you know regular
CRT TV didn't impress me that much I
don't even know that was a Ridley Scott
who directed it
yeah but saw Oliver Harper do a review
on it not me yeah that's really Scott so
I went and got it on blu-ray
it's movies [ __ ] badass movies [ __ ]
bet it's the other Blade Runner it is
kind of like the look of it is very
similar soundscape and everything you
know I think they even lifted some stuff
from like the blade runner's Blade
Runner street scenes yeah and they're
showing I don't know if it was Tokyo or
not it's a Sokka Sokka yeah yeah but it
was kind of you could tell it they kind
of lifted some of the Blade Runner
sounds sound escapes from it yeah it was
a good movie man I liked it yeah like I
said it's interesting I'd remember
seeing this I didn't see in the theater
it came out in 1989 I saw it in the 90s
um I think I rented it or something like
that I don't I didn't remember it being
like a Ridley Scott movie but I remember
really really liking it but I forgot all
about it until like like we said Oliver
Harper like put up a retrospective for
it like a couple weeks ago maybe some
like that a week or two ago and I was
like oh yeah I remember really like in
that movie you know maybe we should do a
retrospective on that so he ended up
ordering it we watched it I remember
being impressed with when I first saw it
right but no you know I mean I saw he
was showing it I was like yeah that
movie was that that movie was that good
yeah cuz it looked like [ __ ] on CRT t
know everything that everything did and
I was like wow I saw it again and I was
like oh man oh yeah [ __ ] I got this an
out I've even seen some stuff even the
[ __ ] Friday the 13th movies like look
like [ __ ] masterpieces of cinema
yeah in comparison like with like when
you watch a little icon two old VHS and
now when you watch them now they've all
been restored something like wow that's
actually a competition yeah this movie
is much more enjoyable than I remembered
it yeah I mean technically it's like um
it's interesting because I think Ridley
Scott he got involved
this project now prior to this I don't
know if there was another movie before
this but he had done you know Blade
Runner
obviously in 82 which you know now is a
classic but at the time yeah it was it
was kind of a bomb he had done legend in
1985 I think that was 85 or 86 which
also I really like that movie but it's I
didn't like it I thought was a girl's
movie the time you and your girls yeah
yeah I don't like it as much as
labyrinth but Tim Curry and legend I
mean the [ __ ] makeup on that was
amazing so I the story's a little fin
but like I thought it was pretty cool
and like I saw a whole bunch of times
and you know growing up but that was
also kind of a flop so I believe that
this was the first movie that Ridley
Scott had worked on after that and it
seemed like I think a lot of the
criticism this movie that Black Rain got
was people thought well it's like it's a
good movie but they thought that he was
playing it too safe because essentially
it's like a standard cop movie is what
it is it's just kind of set in Osaka set
among the Yakuza which was kind of like
you know there were some other movies
that came out like I think a Rising Sun
wasn't [ __ ] Sean Connery and that and
stuff like that that was also kind of
like the Yakuza were the bad guys so I
felt like there was a couple other
movies that came out around that time
what what this movie reminded me of
looking back on it I know that Ridley
Scott went back and looked at it all
right there was an old movie I used to
[ __ ] love it my dad my dad saw with
me one time and I think it was on
television when I was a little kid
it was called red Sun yeah and I say not
yeah and it was about an American outlaw
in the Old West okay and he teams up
with a samurai that was a diplomatic and
envoy from Japan he was one of the one
of the Shogun's [ __ ] samurai and they
try to retrieve a stolen sword together
and it was really it was about honor
yeah and you had a guy who was super
honorable samurai and then a guy who was
a thief but turns out he had honour too
that was played by
Charles Bronson okay yeah yeah yeah
Charles Bronson I remember that thing
was really good red Sun I'd like to get
that on blu-ray too but I think you can
watch it for free on YouTube yeah and
this had a lot of elements of red Sun
yeah I had a bad cop who was an American
and a good cop who's Japanese but it
turns out that the bad cop who was
America was also a good cop he has to
know that it was just another form of
Honor he well and he was a flawed
character yeah which I thought was
really interesting now Michael Douglas
plays the lead in this and I think he
was kind of one of the ones that you
know kind of got the ball rolling
getting this made because he read the
screenplay which I think was written by
a Craig bulletin and he had been the
writer had been in Japan with like a
friend of his or visiting a friend or
something like that and he had seen
these big like American cars and like
these kind of gangster type guys get out
he's like what the hell is that all
about and he said oh it's Yakuza it's
like the Japanese mafia and the writer
had never heard of that before so then
he kind of like got into it and research
it and stuff and he wrote this story
about like because he was interested by
the whole idea of like an American cop
being like a fish out of water and like
kind of the contrast between the way
American cops work in the way Japanese
cops were like the whole like um you
know the the cultural differences
between the two and he thought it would
make an interesting story
yeah and they tried to make they make
this cop as American as possible and
he's hi Eric and his [ __ ] yeah and you
said he's kind of a bad cop from New
York yeah kind of Nick kind of it well
actually a lot of a dick and Connor
you're not really so sure about the guy
is Connor it's kind of sleazy yeah and
he's under investigation Beckett hidden
his department for yeah theft
she honesty I'm taking some [ __ ] off the
top like a drug deal drugs and stuff I
do like the fact that and I remembered
this when I first saw it they
established real early that the guy
could ride a motorcycle and he's pretty
good at it yeah he has I think he had a
Harley had a big a come back model where
they took a Harley Sportster and I think
they [ __ ] short stroked it made it a
1000 I don't remember I think I might
have been I think I might have been
called a an XR 1000 I'm
sure that's probably what it was called
and it was a Sportster that they can't
ride turn into a sport bike they put a
little bubble fairing on the front of it
and kind of gave it a pointed tail in
the back like a Japanese bike from the
seventies and well I'm opening scenes
they show him he's hanging out with all
the Harley Davidson dudes and he's got
his little Harley XR I think it's called
an XR and he challenges a dude on a
system yeah so there's so even before he
goes to Japan there's this whole USBs
and going up is a street drag race you
know the man yeah that bike a Sportster
has a lot of low-end torque you know I
mean from a dead stop it can quickly
pull away but given enough not enough
distance that Japanese four would outrun
it easily but what they do is they show
that the road conditions were bit the
road conditions were bad there's a lot
of stuff that you had to like obstacles
it was obstruction like cones yeah it
was in case if they showed it wasn't the
bike it was the rider really the the
head one and there so they're
established and early on that that
what's his name Doug Donald a Michael
Douglas's character Nick Macklin is the
name here because that's there's a nick
that's right they establish or earlier
that Nick one can ride a motorcycle
because that comes into play later well
yeah you can ride a motorcycle and he
wins by kind of like a combination of
skill and cheating yeah which that comes
it's kind of like a microcosm of hell
yeah like US versus Japan and also he's
she got of a dick she D Anjali cheating
a little bit and just trying to win yeah
so but I really liked early on that they
kind of established that character in
that scene he's like kind of the
quintessential he reminds me a lot of
you know Mel Gibson you know what I mean
in the Lethal Weapon movies a baby I
don't know if it's just the hair yeah
because what they did with Michael
Douglas because he had been in Wall
Street he had been in fatal attraction
so when he got and he actually got the
two producers that worked on fatal
attraction with him he got them
interested in doing this screenplay and
they were
very excited about it so they got Ridley
Scott on and everything like that but
the costume designer cracks me up
because the costume designer was talking
about Michael Douglas like you know he'd
been playing a little bit he was a
little bit sleazy obviously and the
other movies but he's like I want she's
like I wanted him to look like kind of
cool and hip because if you weren't
around in 1989 having a sort of mullet a
sort of hairdo what I mean
see Lost Boys yeah other things but she
said also I wanted him to look kind of
like a sleaze yeah now they borrowed the
haircut from lethal weapon that's yeah
that's what I was really reminded I
could tell that but really the character
is very much Charles Bronson's
characters from red Sun that's where I
think they got that character from it's
pretty much that same character so it's
Charles Bronson's role yeah that's very
similar very similar way you described
but then it's merged in but you could
tell this is really Scott talking now
Nick is kind of like a mixture of like I
said Charles Bronson from red Sun and
Deckard from Blade Runner yeah because
he does do a lot of Decker it's kind of
like private investigative [ __ ]
technique it kind of does that it's a
little underhanded but it's similar so
it does kind of have that that kind of
film noir private dick element to it
kind of but it's more cyberpunk it's a
little more futuristic it's taking place
in Japan and it's filmed in a way where
it looked futuristic compared to the
United States at that time
yeah it did and that's kind of one of
the underlying themes I think is this is
not only the cultural difference but
also a little bit of a rivalry because I
mean what ends up happening is that Nick
Conklin he's played by Michael Douglas
him and his partner who's played by a
very charming Andy Garcia you know he's
like the likable one whereas like
Michael Douglas is kind of like the
douche but I mean he's kind of like a
jerk but you know he's had a rough life
like I said his you know his wife
divorcing me as like alimony payments
and child support and all this other
kind of crap and he's really kind of
like I have seen it all right he's gotta
like you know that kind of guy
and there they happen to be in a
restaurant they see like essentially a
Yakuza hit like somebody comes in and
like you know rubs out a bunch of people
yeah it's cool the way they did short
Yakuza dude Manny little York Yakuza
torpedo pulls out this little Biddy
remember the mini Uzi little mini Izzy
with the side folder he had that and
they put on a big show before and then
the other guy goes in there slits the
other dudes throat then he slit his
throat he stabbed him and yeah we stab
him in the neck something stabbed in the
neck or something something like that
aren't really memories like in the
middle of a crowded restaurant and then
he just basically kind of takes a bow in
front of bachchan the the villain in
this is really cool Sasha oh yeah is
this Japanese and he's caught up to
Japanese Yakuza guy he's kind of stylish
and and tall and wearing cool clothes
and he's kind of bucking his system too
he doesn't like the Yakuza boss is over
him yeah he's trying to cause I think
yeah trying to carve out his own fiefdom
but that all comes out and it all
unfolds before you in in that yeah it's
almost kind of like they're making there
he's making a parallel between
between Nick and Sato yeah and also you
know the the old Yakuza boss soo guy I
think is his name like that there's a
rivalry there to just be kind of like
the old guard in the new guard and it's
like they're accusing Sato being too
much like an American because he's like
cocky and he just kind of goes off and
he does like his own thing and he
doesn't like follow rules are followed
tradition and it's like he just wants to
be like an American and he's just like
after money and [ __ ] like that
so there's like a lot of that kind of
[ __ ] going on - the guy that played Sato
I think his name his name is a yuusaku
Matsuda he actually he was in a [ __ ] ton
of stuff he was I think he did like mute
he might have done like music and chef
she's up to you but he was like on TV he
was in commercials and stuff he actually
died the same year this came out he was
only 40 years old he had like bladder
cancer isn't that creepy yeah because he
looks really young in this movie is he
was he was only 40 years old but yeah
and it's apparently onset they didn't
really know that he was dying now Jenny
said it was kind of a cop buddy movie it
cottage
is but it kind of is not a buddy movie
it's a kind of like a hard-boiled
captain right yeah because it does cut
it did kind of follow the cop buddy
motif for a while but Ridley Scott you
know I mean he's not gonna tolerate that
the buddy gets killed yeah
all right the yellow alert who'sa kill
him and Nick tries to go on a quest to
catch the dudes that did it but the
Japanese police don't want him around
and they basically try to kick him out
of the country but he may be but they
failed to kick him out he escapes off
the damn plane and his only way to get
vengeance and to restore honour for his
fallen partner is to basically go to
work for the Yakuza to go kill the right
the the rival Yakuza gang that did it
yeah and spoiler alert
the Japanese cop that was working with
him kind of understands that in order to
[ __ ] restore the balance you had to
go on the dark side temporarily to get
this dude to kill these dudes yeah and
so the Japanese cop backs him up in it
they go and then they both like fighting
yep they both like learn from each other
right yeah which i think is kind of cool
because when Michael Douglas's character
I keep you know Nick is his name Nick
Conklin when he first goes to Japan I
mean him and his partner they they go
off to Japan they're supposed to take
Sato because the embassy like wanted him
because he's this big like Yakuza boss
so they're like well we want you to just
select a company I'm back to Japan and
then hand him over to the Japanese
authorities and that ends up not
happening the way that it was planned
and then like you know more [ __ ] ensues
but when Michael Douglas firs gets there
it's very funny because it you know he's
almost I don't even want to say almost
he is a very like unlikable character
he's cut he immediately gets off the
plane he's like what the [ __ ] was this
country's like sling is dick all over
[ __ ] Japan it was Scott gets this
directly from red Sun yeah direct you
guys need to see red Sun too if you if
you like Black Rain it's funny black and
red side see red Sun also because that's
god it's it's a it's a cowboy or a
outlaw samurai movie and that's
basically what this is outlaw samurai
movie yeah it's
just veiled it differently but it's that
same idea yeah and in red Sun they're
trying you know a samurai's traveling
with an outlaw to try to regain the
Emperor's sword it wasn't the Shogun
sword was the Emperor's sword because
they just were converted over to kind of
like a republic in a way but the samurai
were still around it was in a
transitional period good good movie but
if you like Black Rain you'd like red
Sun yeah but it's like yeah it's a
similar thing so Michael Douglas is
basically like making a nuisance of
himself and all the Japanese police are
like you know we need to get this guy at
it cuz he's like really loud and
obnoxious and he keeps like showing up
at their crime scenes and like I said
he's kind of Sling as a dick all over
Osaka and he's pissing everyone off but
in some ways to like the the guy that he
you know the Japanese cop that he gets
partnered with who's played by Ken
Takakura which is really interesting
because that guy that actor he had been
in like over 200 movies I think he was
in the lone wolf and cub movies yeah
he's one of them yeah he usually plays a
bad guy he usually like he plays he
plays Yakuza bosses like or he'd played
them like in a whole bunch of movies so
that he's kind of like playing against
type a little bit cuz he's playing a
good guy in this and it actually works
really well because there's a whole like
thing between you know after Nick's
partner is killed and you know him and
the Japanese cop have to work together
and they're like really like butting
heads because they're completely at odds
because he you know the Japanese guys
like no we have to do everything like
exactly right and we have to do this any
other and he's just like [ __ ] no man
we're just gonna go like beat people up
and everything will work itself out the
endian army but they like I said they
kind of come too you know neither one of
them are completely right it's like they
both kind of have to move toward the
middle and come to like some kind of
solution which I thought was kind of
like a cool yeah in another angle that
this movie has in common with red Sun is
that when black rain came out um what's
it name Michael Douglas he went on kind
of like an apology tour he thought and
some other people thought that the movie
mist portrayed or made the Japanese look
bad the
did they know that [ __ ] was a hit in
Japan the Japanese love this movie it
got nominated as for Best Foreign Film
or whatever like into their version of
the Oscars or whatever cuz the Japanese
have Yakuza movies and and Ridley Scott
nailed it
yeah and then and the Japanese guys that
he has in this moves are big stars in
Japan and the sometimes played against
type
but the Japanese loved that [ __ ] yeah
they [ __ ] loved it and it's it could
stand right there along with some of the
best Japanese Yakuza movies so Ridley
Scott [ __ ] knocked it out of the park
yeah well that was the same way that was
the same thing with red Sun red Sun was
a bigger hit in Japan than it was in the
United States that that cowboy samurai
dynamic plays super well in Japan
because the samurai and the the samurai
the Yakuza movies are the cowboy movies
of Japan yeah the Japanese know that
they watch western movies too they love
those they love John Wayne
they love actually the one of the they
love Clint Eastwood movies yeah in Japan
I mean he's got a huge following and
it's because the western movie to a
Japanese person feels traditional that
feels like one of their traditional
samurai movies right yeah the matically
of the era burries it's that same theme
because the Japanese the guys that were
making those Japanese movies were
watching westerns yeah you're like oh
okay yeah yeah we know what this is yeah
we can do that we'll put samurai on
Yakuza in there and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
kids it's the same thing it's that same
story the same idea so it's funny cuz
like Americans think that the Americans
thought that the Japanese were different
no they're just like us everyone's the
same
yeah when you get right down stupid
everyone just has their own take their
own take on but when you look into it
it's not really that different yeah they
weren't insulted they were like honor
doesn't caught man is a badass flick
yeah they weren't and honestly watching
it now um I don't see what they're
talking about not really it doesn't make
the Japanese you know it's Yakuza and
they're bad guys but it's like you know
what I mean guys they have bad guys in
Japan there's bad guys in Japan and most
of the guys are good guys yeah it's like
yeah they're kind of making it look like
oh you know they want to do everything
by the book and that's but that's the
way it was but that's what's made
you know you don't be able to catch him
but like I said they kind of come to a
compromise in the end it's like where
they they kind of make Michael Douglas's
character you know the American he
doesn't turn out to be completely right
either because yeah kind of gets his
partner killed he does some dumb [ __ ]
yeah so he ends up not being completely
right but then like the Japanese end up
not being completely right either they
have to kind of meet in the middle yeah
see the issue was with the good guys the
Japanese good guys in the movies is that
the cops couldn't really get the job
done because they were too restricted by
a bunch of bureaucracy yeah
and they had to have their way to get it
done and their way was was involved a
lot of [ __ ] little nitpicking and
[ __ ] they couldn't do it directly
well you think Japanese weren't
frustrated by that system [ __ ] right
they're frustrated by that system they
didn't like that system either they
wanted direct action and that's why the
Japanese character in this movie the cop
says [ __ ] it we're just gonna go for it
this we said yeah well how come he got
suspended have you got suspending the
words gonna go over because the the
police system was preventing them from
restoring honor and restoring justice to
what you say so because the Yakuza would
play against the cops weaknesses right
they knew how to play against those well
yeah and that was exactly like the
wedding that's why they did it that's
kind of what they were show and it's
funny because ironically when they
because they they wanted to initially
shoot this in Tokyo but they were like
now it's too expensive and like a lot of
the architecture wasn't really what um
what Ridley Scott wanted like what he
imagined like for the visuals of it so
they ended up shooting in Osaka and
they're like at first we didn't really
have a problem but then after a while
all this bureaucracy kind of came to the
fore words like you know you had to like
have permits to do everything and it's
like you can't even like move the camera
like without getting the [ __ ]
permission to do this and you have to if
you're gonna move it over there and
stuff so he's like so we shot most of it
in Osaka but then like it was getting to
be such a pain that a lot of the crew
were like wanted to quit so some of the
[ __ ] in the movie like some of the club
scenes like the stuff in the underground
garage like where the partner gets
killed or Andy Garcia gets killed and
stuff that they shot that in in the US
because they they just couldn't like
deal with all the could they said it was
weird because at first they said
they were they were cool with it like
you know when they first went to film
there they're like yeah yeah whatever
but then like as it went on I guess they
it's like some kind of public pressures
like I don't want all those Americans in
here like filming a movie or whatever
and it's like then they started getting
hit with all these no you have to have a
permit friend no you have for that like
really like pissed them off and it was
like making the movie cause more to
learn about you Ginny when I watched
when I got done watching this movie I
was very satisfied yeah it's a good
movie and like I said I remembered I
remembered seeing it in the 90s and
really really liking it which is why
when it popped up like him on the Oliver
Harper channel I'm like oh yeah man I
remember that movie that was a really
good movie and like like he said I had
forgotten completely that it was showing
clips from it and I was one and I was
going like damn I remember seeing it and
didn't impress me at the time but you
know I was I was young when I saw it
yeah spoiled and I saw that [ __ ] on TV
and I said that looks like a good movie
man I don't regret buying that one yeah
it's weird because I feel like it's one
of his ones that's forgotten even though
at the time I think it costs thirty
million dollars to make it ended up
ended up making like a hundred and
thirty-four million and it got a couple
of economy Award nominations like for
sound design and stuff
so it was like a big deal and honestly
because you know Ridley Scott's last two
movies which were Blade Runner and
legend I believe hadn't really done that
while at the box office this was kind of
like a big like return to form for him
because after this he did Thelma Louise
which is another movie that I forgot
that released got directed that's a
great movie but I haven't seen this
movie seen if you like Blade Runner you
will like this visually it's very
similar to Blade Runner has that noir
like neon type of life you've seen this
movie and liked it you'd love red Sun
yeah you surprised see that I haven't
seen that for years and years I remember
last last I checked it was it was up on
YouTube for free yeah
but no I think the movies a masterpiece
it's much much better than I remembered
and it was very satisfying
it was they don't make movies like this
anymore it was a weird mixture of a
traditional cop movie with a bunch of
good cool twists on it yeah it you know
I mean in the soundscape justwe shot the
pacing of it I thought was [ __ ]
was optimal I just yeah that was a good
mom Zimmer did the score for this and it
actually ended up being really like
influential like going forward I think
this is the first action movie he had
ever scored he scored movies before this
obviously but this was the first action
when he had done and but I think that
like his theme for this like even like
turned up like in other people's themes
like later on so has a lot more
influential than another movie this
reminded me of was an animated Japanese
animated movie called Akira kind of like
that a little bit where they had the
motorcycle gangs and yeah but visually
it kind of reminded me of a cure if
that's possible yeah you know I mean but
yeah it's badass flick liked it yeah
like it's a cool movie and I even I had
completely forgotten about it until like
I said until it popped up on there I was
like oh yeah we should get those it's
like that was a really good movie I
remember liking it a lot and you know I
don't Kate Capshaw was in it I was just
gonna say by the way Kate Capshaw is in
it um she's not
I mean she's important in the sense that
she knows what's going on with the gang
more and she like feeds Michael Douglas
some information but they don't really
do a lot with her character like it
almost seems like oh there could be like
some romance and stuff but they don't
really go anywhere more of a source of
information that yeah roll along and
she's not um because you know anguish
barrier cuz you know [ __ ] Nick
doesn't speak Japanese right so she's
kind of like if you know what the crazy
thing about it is that like you know all
the main actors in this that were you
know the Japanese actors I don't think
any of them could speak any English no
they were just pretending to speak
English so they just like learned him
phonetically or they just like had
people like kind of feeds it's like I
would have never guessed that in a
million years yeah but yeah so yeah so
Kate Capshaw was kind of like the only
other person that was like you know an
American and you know that he could get
information from and she kind of knew it
was going on cuz she been like living
there and like working in a bar for a
long time and the you know thing is you
know the bad guy was no Sat oh yeah I
was watching him I was going like you
know what dad is a take on the character
Roy yes right yeah Blade Runner yeah did
you notice that - just yeah stylist
you know stylish Lee or they're
stylistically he was wearing and
everything even sometimes kind of the
haircut it wasn't white hair there's
black hair but you just
kind of it's like man they did that's a
Roy batty it's what they're doing yeah
he was like that type of yeah when he
goes to when he goes to see his boss
kind of like Roy batty going to see
Tyrell yeah what went down there it's
like that Sado had some like crazy eyes
yeah cuz he's not um he's not like a big
dude tall but I mean he was tall and
thin yeah but the way that he like
carried himself in this moving the way
he looked at people he was like a really
really good fella they said he was 6 1
and for a Japanese person that's [ __ ]
tall especially back then yeah like I
said you you would never know that he
was like dying of cancer now like
watching this movie and with my mind
he's playing against tight because in
Japan he was known as more of a comic
yeah and he was playing a villain and
[ __ ] evidently the Japanese just went
[ __ ] apeshit for that character yeah
so yeah they had a lot of kind of like
really popular Japanese actors but
playing a type of part that they didn't
usually weigh so that kind of worked in
its advantage also and like I said they
did a [ __ ] great job for not even
speaking any English like I said I never
would have guessed that either yeah but
yeah if you're into Ridley Scott and you
be just like forgot about this one or
you haven't seen it or something and you
like Black Rain it's like it's not like
um you know it's basically it's just a
hard-boiled 80s
cop movie yeah but filtered through
Ridley Scott yeah you know it's a
classic ready Scott someone really
Scott's best stuff yeah I'd say it's a
great movie I don't imbibe that I got it
on blu-ray yeah so yeah definitely um
you know check it out